does work but it's not as effective as
consuming vitamin I just wanted to talk
about this idea that vitamin C
supplements work better than vitamin C
in skin care it's in this book clean by
Dr James hlin which Mina cites I love
Mina I love that she cites her
references but this is a really common
myth even with scientists and doctors
the reason is you can get a much higher
concentration in the skin by going
through the top so putting a skincare
product on and having it soak through
then through the bottom so through the
blood which is where all the stuff that
you eat ends up going and distributing
to the skin vitamin C is water soluble
and that means if you eat too much in
supplements your kidneys will catch it
and you end up peeing it out and this is
called excretion and so there's only a
certain level that you can get into the
blood but there aren't any major
biological mechanisms for excretion in
the top of your skin so when you put
vitamin C on top of there you're going
to get a much higher concentration into
your skin and the evidence does show
that you do need these higher
concentrations to have benefits for skin